a growing number of parents are pleading
not guilty in the massive college
admissions scandal but legal analysts
say they may be taking a huge risk
actress Lori Lachlan and her husband
Massimo Julie both entered not guilty
pleas yesterday so far some 16 parents
have decided to fight the charges at
least 13 including actress Felicity
Huffman pleaded guilty Don Dahler is
outside the federal courthouse in Boston
Don good morning good morning we didn't
see Lori Lachlan nor her husband here
yesterday and that's because they waived
their right to appear before a judge and
instead submitted their not guilty pleas
via two signed statements it was a major
moment in their court battle but it was
far from the last
nearly two weeks after facing charges in
Boston federal court Lorie Lachlan and
her husband Massimo gia newly made it
clear they are not giving in to federal
prosecutors the two signed pleas of not
guilty Monday all but ensuring a lengthy
legal battle Lachlan and Gia newly are
charged with paying $500,000 to
guarantee both of their daughters
admission into the University of
Southern California the criminal
complaints against the couple detail
evidence including emails bank records
and recorded phone calls if they have
real physical evidence against Lori
Lachlan she and her husband are going to
be in for a quick guilty verdict and a
big punishment attorneys for Gregory and
Amy Colburn who are accused of paying
thousands to boost their son's SAT
scores took it a step further Monday
they filed a motion to dismiss saying
while the government's strategy of
lumping together all of the parents into
a single conspiracy has had the intended
effect of creating widespread public
outrage there is no legal basis for
including the Colburn's what the
Colburn's are accusing the government of
is making this broad net this broad
overreach in part to inflame the public
but it doesn't mean that simply because
you didn't know one another that the
charge should fail a source tells CBS
News federal prosecutors have sent
letters to some of the parents adult
children believed to have known about
scam indicating they could also face
criminal charges for Lachlan and her
husband legal experts say there's still
time to change their plea before they go
to trial if at some point they should
change their mind the question is how
much aggravation have they caused the
government so far as well as looking at
how they have finally come to grips with
taking responsibility although
prosecutors say many of the children
were not aware of what their parents
were allegedly doing some court
documents suggest that some of them were
aware in some cases children were
allegedly either on the email strings or
they took part in conference calls
between their parents and the alleged
mastermind of this scandal Wow
that's stunning to hear Don proof that
this story is not over yes no and a
source close to the couple was saying
that they they believed that they were
not breaking the law they acknowledged
though they knew that they were breaking
rules I don't know if that makes it sort
of close to the lock lens yeah tell the
Lachlan got it okay I don't know if that
makes it any better if that was your
reasoning while you were going through
all of this yeah we're just amazed they
could get their kids to sit on a
conference call